we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P uh unfortunately there
are people we launched the the David
packman show Finance Channel we're right
at the cusp of 10 000 subscribers on it
already youtube.com Pacman Finance it's
a beautiful channel it's Financial
education but someone seems confused
about what the channel actually is
amazing YouTube channel I just recall
you saying sir that people should tune
in and you will tell them exactly how to
invest every dollar that they have and
you are a financial genius and you have
made great money on doing this I
remember you saying that and by the way
I'm just kidding I'm so sick of your
reading comprehension challenged
conservative listeners I know who call
in and think they got you because they
made up something in their head it's
like driving me nuts I'd say come on
people good God I mean this isn't even
actually reading comprehension listen to
listening comprehension yeah but uh now
we can see why they're so easily
exploited
that's the conservative sheep not you
exploiting them
all the fun stuff have a good weekend
I'm just calling this because I'm too
lazy to write all right very good and uh
again I am not giving anyone specific
Financial advice on the Pacman Finance
YouTube channel but we do have a ton of
Education topics you can find the
channel at youtube.com pacmanfinance we
are like within 20 subscribers of ten
thousand so if you want to be one of the
first 10 000 check it out recent Clips
include what is your net worth how do
you simply create a basic personal
balance sheet to figure out what is your
net worth
um why is it that we have seen a
declining stock market over the last
several months what factors influence
that how do you improve your credit
score why you should not try to time the
market that's one of the most popular
clips and most controversial I don't
think you should try to time the market
I don't think it's really doable for the
average person and quite frankly even
most money managers fail to correctly
time the market a lot of really good
stuff no Politics on the channel okay
that's youtube.com
pacmanfinance I hope that you will all
join me on today's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves as bad well yeah I mean we're
funded by the audience so in a sense
it's true that with a bonus show makes
money okay Alex uh you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we will talk about job
openings plunging in August is that a
good sign or a bad sign there's two ways
to interpret that a Michigan judge has
dropped felony charges against seven
people in the Flint water Scandal and a
U.S appeals court has sent a DACA case
back to a lower court to consider a new
rule and the implications for DACA
recipients are significant all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
don't miss it